I was like my grandma told me that you
really live life when you have sex in
front of the fireplace and so we had sex
in front of the fireplace in honor of
you
yeah
but that right Kim Kardashian reveals
she had sex with Pete Davidson in honor
of her grandma people don't see the
context behind it let's unpack all that
shall we it's a different experience for
sure the scams founder makes the
hilarious confession during the latest
episode of Hulu's the Kardashians while
catching up with her sister Chloe Mama
dear Chris and Chris's mom MJ you know
it's so crazy Pete and I are staying at
the Beverly Hills Hotel last weekend and
we were sitting in front of the
fireplace just talking for hours and I
was like my grandma told me that you
really live life when you have sex in
front of the fireplace and so we had sex
in front of the fireplace in honor of
you I know that's right in the lobby not
in the lobby yeah
or how creepy to think about your
grandma before you upset I know yeah
it's definitely not not creepy but I was
younger once I was younger once that
racy can chat went down in March long
before Kim and the Saturday Night Live
Alum called it quits in August it is
what it is and in April when the two
were still an item the reality star
swooned over the comedian during a chat
with E.T what do you love about him
what's your favorite thing about him
he's just super genuine yeah and it's
just really fun to just
hang out and do nothing and
watch TV and just do nothing yeah and
clearly the famous fam totally approved
of Keat
Pete is amazing no drama no stress he's
just Pete fits in with the family I
think Kim is happy she laughs she's more
confident Pete brings out the best in
her what do you all love about Pete I
love that he's kind and really really
thoughtful he's the most thoughtful
person and I love the chemistry that Kim
and him have together it's really sweet
and she said the chemistry I was like
okay chemistry chemistry well that
chemistry fizzled out for Kim and Pete
after dating for nine months a source
recently told E.T the comedian is bummed
about their split but is trying to stay
focused and positive quote he has the
utmost respect for Kim her kids and the
family he wants to maintain a healthy
relationship with all of them what kind
of man at this point in your life do you
see yourself with
absolutely no one as for Kim she
recently revealed she's totally fine
with her new single status I'm not
looking for anything I think I really
just need to be by myself and focus and
finish school so law school my kids yeah
[Applause]
[Music]